(light music)
- [Melanie] I told myself going into
the locker room, "Melanie,
when you had breasts you would not
have been modest.
You would not be covering yourself up
to any greater degree.
So this is what you will do now."
When the doctor told me,
"I'm sorry to say you have breast cancer,"
I just went blank.
(gurgling)
(light music)
I was diagnosed needing
a single mastectomy
of my right breast.
I knew from the start
that I wasn't interested
in reconstruction.
Symmetry is important to me.
As an individual.
It's my breasts or nothing.
Shopping for that bathing suit.
(sighing)
That was hard.
You know, I have 17 inches
of scar on my chest.
My skin doesn't move the way it used to.
And it needs stretching.
Doing it in the water just feels better
than anything else anywhere else.
(inspirational music)
When I made this decision,
I told myself,
"Just embrace this.”
"Be it.”
"Be all of it."
I've posed for a few different projects.
The Grace Project.
I've posed for Play Out Underwear.
These projects, they're great for me.
There's an aspect of
being able to see myself.
I'm not defined by my breasts,
or my lack of breasts.
Visual representation for this body type
is very important so that no women feel
like they need to hide.
(light music)